questo video io fare tanti ragazzi
ovviamente questo video sono pochi j
qui e stefano e sono abusivo in camera
sua oggi ho deciso di fare una roba
carina che se nome diventa figo non lo
so se riusciremo a farla è questo che la
cantina epico e volevo non vuoi
lui non voleva farlo però il doe
costretti a giocare a minecraft nab
adwords e bed stuy praticamente io un
uovo il personaggio quindi con una mano
e lui muove la visuale con l'altra
secondi in due come andiamo un
personaggio è difficilissimo gli spieghi
perché sembra una merda più del solito
li facciamo allora bei ragazzi siamo
operativi il fatto che se non facciamo
italy in lobby che devo andare ad
ottobre è questo meno qui tu mi devi
devi dire indirizzare perché se non ama
certo forse non ha capito che non è così
semplice ma che aveva 18 giocatori
dobbiamo uccidere otto persone che può
fare se siamo in due come fare e la
crown casino veloce però se succedere se
non succede ma se succede quando partiva
subito all indietro
dietro mai dove vado a prendere contro
ad arrivati a 12 no no indietro ancora
ok arrivati ad un nuovo impossibile
dobbiamo data alluminio a comprare 11 12
vai vai vai vai perché fai così vai
verso il muro premi shift avanti e shift
out e vuoi fare contemporanea indietro
shift poi il buio ci siamo quasi non
lasciare ancora puoi lasciare poi
lasciate in faccia siamo chiamati a via
via via veloce la pentola di sparare
ricordino badare devi correre addosso
tutto il nostro lessico di corri corri
corri doveva inseguire dov'è
picchia la vecchia lo metti alla vecchia
non è in picchiata in quanto vali
incontro all'incontro muore muore muore
marmore ucciso benissimo sta tornando
sta arrivando tipo buttò giù
allora si cambia
allora adesso l'unico modo che mi viene
in mente difendersi finire un muro
gigante ma non è che con mancate la
maggior parte delle cose le fai col
cazzo di calchi mouse o falsa che scadrà
anche una sola cosa impedito è lo so ma
è difficile in due perché diano marina
casuale ecco ecco ecco
occhio però scendere fa lo scemo che
cazzo fa è scemo no idea cosa falsa si
ispirino tutto cuore vorrei assoluta
sono mal di schiena ha fatto tutto il
casino appostati diamanti ci ha portato
diamanti cresce a venire qui ok un altro
perfetto fornace potenziata ancora ecco
ieri merda va bene va bene è tornato sta
tornando in black axe 8 sai che ti dico
una cosa potremmo ucciderlo volendo come
dobbiamo bisognerà finiti mai avanti una
tnt e una mela
se si può rifare questa cosa mangiano
l'havana noche uccisi testa di mentre
preparava il piano le ne facciamo
un'altra dai che sfiga siamo stati anche
sfortunati e questi sono preso di mira
immediatamente il ponte per il centro va
fatto per i diamanti
perché dobbiamo prendendo 6 maschili che
però stai parlando possiamo provare a
fare gli stronzi subito se ci riusciamo
siamo dio per vai vai alla corri in base
compriamo subito l'upgrade bike bike
tornato a loro a volte difficile ma è di
stato perché sta facendo il collegamento
dall'altro quindi possiamo spaccargli la
base quando mi va dalla rai
sono 20 i blocchi circa vai ai grossi
attento girati tra pochino salis alisa
lì ok come non ci sto chiudendo a noi
spacca villetta la squadra andrea
ucciderlo le uccideva javito laggiù
tutto merito vero ma il nostro letto
chissenefrega ma poi bisogna essere a
nessuno e lui nostro vicino
oddio ecco no scontino lì a bada
arcavacata questo caso dai blog e dai
blocchi quindi e quindi stando in tutte
le basi nostri madonna sta cadendo
indicazione uno spaccato il letto è già
tanto se riuscite fossero ben due vale
qualcosa come no no no
via di qui vai e cha cha cha cha veloce
sono ben 999 che non è un problema mio
piccolo spaccato il lato di nuove
prossimo terzino smile ispanica merda
no ho preso peso è però lo potevi uscire
i corridori non uccidiamo ricarica
ricorrente capita 18 arrivati non ti fa
buttare di sotto di battuta e sotto
questo leggendo attaccano la merda no
l'ultima volta è la pausa avanti e
questo con una svolta non torniamo
indietro ma avanti e mai tipo ci aveva
già visto secondo adesso la nostra prima
dobbiamo fare è correre verso la spacca
glielo se ci ha visto non c'è già vi
fermate calati un secondo ma è ancora
qua ra qua tematico riusciti a uccidere
la spagna diaz al pai iron a basso costo
da sono stato storico ed è no ora
dobbiamo fare gli incontri altamente è
l'unico modo per ucciderlo
c'è pochissima vita mai laico ricordi
subito corri corri corri così vado mai
capito ciò che facciamo ce la facciamo
ahi ahi velocissimo salta salta non se
la ripresa
salta salta salta salta santos emorme
abbiamo vinto salta ora salta ma la
ripresa nella ripresa abbiamo linea
furtivo non ci sto credendo la firma
arriva dalla meno sobri lasciare al
quarto a ryanair ci mostrerà i sono
incredibili fermo fermo che c'è un buco
libero e rami base da sopra lanciamo la
tnt spacchiamo con la copertura cia del
letto se gli rimane un materiale senso
così abbiamo il piccone gli spacchiamo
possiamo uccidere anche lui se uccidiamo
due team su sette perché alla fine non
siamo noi quindi non sono solo sette
siamo troppo foro ho capito tutto quello
che hai detto facciamo
questa volta sono carico è un salto la
sopra vai o chi o che cosa significa un
po a sinistra faccia realistico no no no
no scegliamo la voce nello scendere
sopra può un po a destra sua scelta di
che cazzo stai decisa da bbc falsificato
fondamentale 12
oddio sei pronto per stare scendiate bye
bye
non è perchè l'ha fatto per il letto dai
mio addio incredibile il verde non può
più permettersi di morire altrimenti ha
perso ragazzo ma non c'è adesso
parleremo la spada quella vera cech e
tattiche usate devastante parte lo
perdiamo alvaro base anche a noi o no
allagato spero di sì per chi non ne sono
alla fiaba e non lasciano spazi così in
base arrivato 3 2 1 è sopra di noi e è
sopra di noi a sopra di noi attento
attento aperto subito agli assalti sono
l'opposto dall'armatura me la potente e
ucciderlo voleva tutto da sola fa dai
che palle tu da solo lui usava di
entrambe le mani su tastiere e computer
avere quello sì ma la vera caccia
abbiamo proprio stato figo ma ce la
facciamo normale spero che questa roba
vi sia piaciuta prossima volta girano
sono quei piedi che salva luca tastiera
così che ragazzi spero che vi sia
piaciuto passato anche al calini stefano
ben fatto mediatico insieme quasi sede
vicino al momento mi piace ai gay sono
seguite totale a schizzare il social
sisti gli altri ci vediamo al prossimo
vito beh ragazzi ma che vuole non c'è
stata ma se cara è il pallone
eccomi servizio natale va bene beh
ragazzi mi sento freddo in questo modo
[Musica]